hey you yeah you I give you games i lo  in the game any game oh you're a triple  duty army I love you too grandma  okay bye bye now but grandma well if you  do I am proud to announce that I will be  the first weekly host of the Humble  Bundle weekly they asked me to select my  five top favorite indie games so we put  them all together and the coolest part  about it is that you pay whatever you  like for it this is also part of the  charity water campaign that we're  running so if you want to you can select  part of what you pay to go towards the  charity supporting the developers  support charity and get awesome games so  what are you waiting for  check out the link in description I love  all these games I'm sure you both will  as well  [Music]  you